[Music]
an excellent organization is one where
people do the right thing even when
nobody's watching them over their
shoulder because that's what makes you
best-in-class that's actually what makes
you innovative that's actually what's
the foundation for being a place that
employees love to work so that's the
hardest thing how do you build an
organization where people know the right
thing even when nobody is watching all
over them
accountability to me is not a list of
metrics accountability is what you feel
so felt accountability is the important
thing and from my point of view there
are two foundations one is a feeling of
psychological ownership the other is the
sense of obligation and each one
balances the other if it's 100 percent
psychological ownership zero or percent
obligation it becomes a gateway to being
egocentric on the other hand if it's
hundred percent obligation and no sense
of psychological ownership that becomes
burdensome and therefore unsustainable
so you need a blend of both things
the problem I have with most executives
is all that they think about is Jesus
we've got a crank the incentive lever in
short we gotta pay people more the more
people we pay people apparently the more
accountable they feel I'm not so sure
instead you can actually do more
lightweight things as a matter of fact
with my colleague Lindy Greer and a
wonderful graduate student Jennifer
Daniels the three of us did an
interesting experiment with 82 new
venture teams what did we do we randomly
put these teams into two conditions the
control condition which I won't bother
you about and then a treatment condition
these teams were teams of four to five
people and all the PR team members in
the treatment condition was choose a job
title that showcases your unique
strengths them you know people came up
with titles like guru of software or the
queen bee of customer service or the
defender of the chord or whatever it was
amazing the group the teams where people
chose their own job titles what did it
do it actually made them feel less
anonymous obviously it improved their
sense of self-esteem but much more
importantly it also solved the problem
of who knows what in the team they were
able to build prototypes that were
quicker and better than others in the
control condition my question to you is
does it cost you anything to ask people
to come up with their own title
in most organizations when I look at
high performers on average high
performance can be categorized into two
buckets one bucket is high performers
who are high maintenance they need to be
stroked they need to be paid they need
to be recognized and they're extremely
self-centered on the other hand there
are other high performers who have been
referred to as extra milers and what do
they do they perform well but they're
also the most helpful people they're the
go-to people when you run into a problem
hey how do I deal with this customer
problem how do I deal with the
technology problem it's these extra
milers that do the most it turns out
most executives they overload the
extra-mile errs you're never going to go
to your high maintenance high
performance high performer and say can
you please do that they'll just
immediately want a lot of things from
you you instead go to your extra milers
they're very good at what they do what's
their principal weakness they don't know
how to say no to you or for that matter
anybody so ironically the more you
overload them the more overwhelm they
get and some studies have actually shown
if you overload them with too many
requests they actually begin to develop
intentions of leaving the company is
that what we want to do I think
[Music]
you